ça tombe sans sa tombe à l'image va
faire un petit tour de magie regarde la
ferme ce tour de magie c'est de la merde
ça va ça trop pas marché j'ai annulé mon
tour de magie en live je voulais faire
changer la chaise mais ça marche pas
c'est sûr je tente quand même est-ce que
ça a marché ce qu'on a vu le cut ou pas
je sais pas les amis bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle vidéo bienvenue dans
cette deuxième édition du show le plus
aimé du tout non plus sérieusement j'ai
vu tous vos retours sur le premier à
quoi j'ai totalement compris et ce que
vous reprochez aux trucs etc
et c'était très bienveillant d'ailleurs
vos commentaires donc merci pour tous
ces retours ça m'a fait plaisir c'est
vrai qu'habituellement quand on a
beaucoup de jeunes parents ce bras qu'on
n'est pas bien et est dans les
commentaires c'est pas très constructif
mais là c'était tout l'inversé donc
merci pour ça c'est important de le
souligner aujourd'hui un ya quoi édition
spéciale une énorme bombe qui a eu sur
les réseaux sociaux ya pas longtemps
avez vous entendu parler de ce fameux
nom la ligue du lol certainement alors
petit disclaimer je suis pas du tout
journaliste si vous voulez voir des
articles complets un vrai travail de
journaliste baal et en descriptions
j'aurais mis pas mal de lire qui peuvent
vous être utile je fais cette vidéo
juste pour ouvrir le dialogue sur ce qui
s'est passé et pour du coup de
sensibiliser ceux qui me suivent
vis-à-vis du harcèlement qui est quelque
chose de terrible et commençons par le
commencement début février on voit
apparaître sur twitter plusieurs
témoignages qui parle de harcèlement des
victimes sortent du silence donc ça fait
un peu de bruit mais pas tant que ça
quelques jours après il ya un article du
site de questions/réponses check in use
ainsi qui appartient à libération qui
révèle de nombreuses accusations et
preuve de harcèlement perpétré par un
certain groupe dont le nom serait la
ligue du lol s'ensuit alors un clash sur
twitter avec d'un côté alexandre hervaud
le boss du service web de libération et
de l'autre côté iris qu'avait et daria
marx pourquoi il a clash parce que ces
dernières trouvent que l'arctique il est
trop succinct que c'est trop vite par
rapport aux sujets traités et qui a
beaucoup plus de choses que ça à dire
florence purcell et capucine piot décide
le lendemain de prendre la parole pour
témoigner pareil du harcèlement qu'elles
ont subies à partir de là effet boule de
neige mais dans le bon sens les victimes
de ce groupe se rendre compte qu'elles
sont pas seuls que d'autres gens
beaucoup de gens ont subi ça et elle
voit ses audiences en train de sortir du
silence et du coup elles vont elles
mêmes sortir du silence et témoigner
donc on comprend que il ya un seul et
même groupe qui a harcelé toutes ces
personnes voilà j'espère que tout est
clair pour vous à partir de là cela
petite intro pour vous faire comprendre
comment tout ça et a été amené sur le
tapis vous savez on va mais qu'est ce
que la ligne du lol lucas c'est quoi
c'est des mecs juste qu'ils font des
tweets un peu drôle et les gens rt pas
du tout je profite stop
désolé mais quand à lui tous les
témoignages teint seulement toi qu'est
kefu la ligue du lol c'est un groupe
constitué essentiellement de
homme qui passait son temps à comme ils
disent rires trop laid mais pas du tout
il passait juste leur temps à harceler
d'autres gens qui étaient
essentiellement des femmes donc on avait
le droit des insultes sexistes des
insultes homophobes des insultes
racistes bref vous prenez tout ce qui se
fait de pire tout ce qu'il se fait de
pire et qui peut sortir de la bouche
d'un humain bas ça sortait de la bouche
d'eric dulon le niqab les membres du
groupe c'est essentiellement un cercle
de journalistes et de communicants qui
bossait dans des rédactions ou dans des
agences de pub influentes à paris alors
il faut savoir que c'était des gens
majeur n'était pas un groupe d'enfants
de 15 ans qu'ils savaient pas ce qu'ils
faisaient c'est des gens qui avaient la
vingtaine au moins la vingtaine y en a
même certains qui avait la trentaine
donc à s'acharner parfaitement
responsable ok faut arrêter ces
conneries de j'étais jeune non non non
non non non et là une question me
taraude
aidez-moi éclairer ma lanterne qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire dans la vie quand on
est un homme blanc et en plus on a un
travail et si on allait exploser ceux
qui galèrent et qui débute yes les
membres de la ligue du lol parler donc
entre eux sur un groupe facebook privé
qui s'appelle la ligue du lot les gens
qu'elle y poster photo montage dégradant
des infos persos des trucs horribles sur
les gens et sur leurs potentielles
cibles ça sortait sur un groupe privé
sauf que derrière bien entendu ça
sortait en public y mettait ça sur les
réseaux sociaux ils mettaient au point
des stratagèmes pour vraiment affecter
le plus la vie de la personne lui faire
le plus de mal possible à traîner
vraiment dans la boue publiquement et
c'est là où ça devient un gros bordel
qui fait du mal à beaucoup de gens et
c'est ignoble il est aussi important de
noter que la ligue du lol c'est pas un
groupe qui contient un nombre de membres
précis et c'est ok il ya des gens qui
ont créé ce groupe privé qui s'appelait
la ligue du lol mais il ya aussi plein
d'autres gens qui sont tout aussi
coupable et qui était pas dans le groupe
mais qui ont suivi les agissements des
gens du groupe et ce genre là essayer de
se dédouaner en disant non moi j'étais
pas dans l'élite du lol mais mec tu
faisais exactement la même chose c'est
pas parce qu'il a pas marqué vive
douleur au début ton pseudo que tu vaux
mieux que en fait alors lucas c'est bien
moi tu nous parles à l'idole des gens
qui sont méchants qui ont harcelé mais
ils ont fait quoi en fait on veut du
concret mais ça arrive
laissez-moi construire ma vidéo avec
plusieurs points clés alors je voulais
dit il s'attaquait essentiellement aux
femmes magnifiques donc les mêmes
choisissez une cible c'est un petit jeu
pour eux et ils se mettaient ensuite à
l'attaqué
c'était plusieurs dessus en plus de ça
c'est des gros lâche t il attaquer à
base de publication de photos montages
dégradant d' insulte tout ce qui pouvait
mettre en place et qui allait décourager
la personne face à qu'ils étaient et lui
faire du mal
je sais c'est chelou comme but dans la
vie de faire ça mais c'était leur but
est apparemment pour vous dire à quel
point ces des oufs les mecs allait même
jusqu'à demander des informations
personnelles sur la cible qu'ils avaient
choisis auprès de ses collègues les plus
proches il ya un problème dans le
cerveau clairement bref on va parler de
concret en se basant sur un
témoignage en se basant sur le
témoignage de @ leur ai dit pourquoi je
parle de son témoignage à lui et pas de
l'un d'eux tous les autres que j'ai vu
parce que c'est son témoignage à lui que
j'ai lus en premier et que m'a donc mis
la puce à l'oreille alors disclaimer il
s'agit ici d'un homme blanc hétéros qui
du coup ne représente pas du tout la
majorité des victimes de la ligue du lol
qui était comme je voulais 10 ans
seulement des femmes je vais donc
reprendre point par point ce qui lui est
arrivé en reprenant ses propos je vais
pas déformer ce qu'il arrive quoi que
soit j'ai vraiment vous expliquez lui
tout ce qu'il a vécu vous pouvez
retrouver une énorme partie des autres
témoignages en description comme je vous
ai dit je mettrai tous les liens qu'il
faut c'est donc quelqu'un qui à l'époque
c'était à plusieurs années la sono je
vous parle tenait un blog sur lequel il
partageait ses états d'âme voilà il
écrivait des textes c'est cool alors
quelqu'un comme vous et moi et quand ils
tombent sur ça soit ça va l'intéresser
et va lire il va kiffer soit ça
m'intéresse pas et il passe à autre
chose et ils ignorent mais quelques uns
des ligues du lol
il va juste dire à mes seins fragile lui
venez on va se moquer un peu sur les
réseaux a à l'oeil nu le gros nul il
écrit des textes et il y met des
sentiments de dans le grund nul
j'exagère même pas c'est vraiment ça
qu'ils disent donc déjà dans cette
démarche et andré blais bref son
harcèlement ça donc commencé par
recevoir des insultes sur twitter venant
de comptes twitter appartenant à la
ligue du lol sauf qu'ils aient un effet
boule de neige comme les mecs de la
ligue du lol à l'époque faut se dire que
c'était vraiment les kings de twitter
qu'ils avaient des énormes communauté
sur twitter est bon il ya des gens qui
suivaient ce qui faisait en pensant que
c'était bon enfant en pensant que
c'était cool de faire ça que c'était
stylet et du coup ces gens ces gens là
qui étaient hors de la ville du locle se
sont mis à les suivre et à insulter du
coup le riz à se moquer de la même
manière que les gens de la ligue du lol
leur ai dit quelque chose de hyper
intéressant qui fait bien comprendre ce
que c'est que le harcèlement dans son
témoignage il dit que c'est
l'accumulation de chaque petit acte
individuel qui finit par faire très très
très très mal et c'est vrai et c'est
important de le souligner parce que les
personnes qui ont harcelé quand tu quand
ils présentent leurs excuses ils disent
mais ça va j'ai juste fait ça ça va
c'est rien ils ont pas conscience qu'en
fait il ya des dizaines ou centaines
d'autres personnes qui ont fait la même
chose qu'eux et que l'accumulation de
tout ça c'est ce qui fait ultra mal je
peux vous dire que les harceleurs là ils
en avaient pas conscience parallèlement
à ça il ya même un mec est allé jusqu'à
créer un compte qui s'appelait le report
et non du coût de grille donc à usurper
totalement son identité et à aller sur
des blogs de copines feminista le riz
pour les insulter faire des insultes
sexistes mais au gym ça bon vous
connaissez tout ce qui est pire quoi
sauf que du coup les copines et le riz
pensant que c'était vraiment le riz qui
avait commenté salon appelé il ya eu des
engueulades et embrouillé etc bref
usurpé l'identité de quelqu'un pour
provoquer les réactions au sein de sa
vie privée c'est pitoyable
et c'est ce genre de truc que les mecs
font gamme c'est dingue les mecs ne sont
pas arrêtés là ils ont ensuite trouvé
notre technique pour faire chier
le riz en fait ce qu'ils attendent c'est
une réaction de la part du gard ils
veulent vraiment le traîner dans la boue
jusqu'à ce qu'il craque pour ensuite se
[ __ ] de la gueule de sa gueule quand
ils craquent ils ont commencé à lire les
textes les plus sentimentaux delory et à
mettre ça sur un fond de violons triste
pour se [ __ ] de sa gueule
il publie et s'assure saint-claude il
invitait plein de gens à le faire et sur
plusieurs semaines ya eu plus de 20
musique ont été mises en ligne comme ça
sur scène claude et la pochette de
l'album c'était des photos personnelles
de leur pays qu'ils étaient détournées
toujours dans le but de dégrader son
image toujours plus plus tard le riz a
eu une altercation avec l'un de ses
harceleurs dans un bar ils en sont
presque venus aux mains
et après ça le riz a décidé de dévoiler
l'identité de l'un de ses receveurs
publiquement donc son nom prénom et son
adresse là quand on apprend ça on se dit
[ __ ] il ya une justice il lui a mis
dans la gueule un petit pourcentage de
ce que lui il sait manger dans la gueule
c'est bon à votre avis comment réagit le
harceleur comme un bonhomme en mode mais
mec ça m'atteint pas je m'en bats les
couilles pas du tout cette personne
c'est juste offusqué sur les réseaux
sociaux et a trouvé sa pitoyable de la
part de leur pays et ça montre vraiment
à quel point cette personne n'avait pas
conscience de ce qu elle infliger à leur
i de ce qu'elle faisait cette personne
avait aucun recul sur ce qu'elle faisait
ses fous d'être à ce point déconnecté de
la réalité de la conséquence de nos
actes cette personne c'est tout
simplement rangés derrière en faisant un
truc pitoyable il à faire un
photomontage pornographiques avec la
tête de leurs emails envoyés ce montage
photo ap l'un d'eux mineur et leur poser
comme question salut je m'appelle @ le
riz j'adore faire telles positions
sexuelles est-ce que ça t'intéresse donc
il ya deux nouvelles fois usurpation
d'identité qui est le plus gros truc de
lâcher de connard que tu peux faire
parce que les conséquences de sa sont
dévastatrices et donc le rayer recevait
dans ces notifications des gens qui
répondait en fait aux faux le riz qui
leur a envoyé ce photomontage et leur
demander des trucs sexuelle et du coup
ça a commencé à tourner un peu et plein
de gens du coup ont ensuite vu le riz
comme un pédophile
voilà alors qu'il n'a rien commis de
tout ça est ce que rim c'est que du coup
quand il ouvrait twitter dans ces notes
il n'y avait que ça comme le gall avait
mentionné dans sa question dans les
notifications de leurs y avait que ça en
fait que les réponses des mineurs face à
ça du coup je pense que quand il
t'arrive ça t'as plus trop envie
d'ouvrir twitter et du coup tu t'isoles
et c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est
gros chiens ils veulent vraiment isolé
leurs victimes car elles sont encore
plus fragiles et plus facilement
attaquable bref tout ce qu'on peut faire
de plus lâche c'est ce que font les
harceleurs on l'a dit vous juste ça
alors là certains d'entre vous peuvent
se dire mais [ __ ] mais pourquoi les
mecs faisait ça et rester dans
l'impunité la plus totale je veux dire
pourquoi personne n'allait les balances
et pourquoi les victimes ne parlait pas
pourquoi fins et très complexe quand on
est dans la situation d harceler et je
pense qu'on peut même pas imaginer
mais être à leur place tant qu'on n'a
pas vécu vu qu'ils avaient une
communauté énorme savait pas trop
intérêt à te fâcher à temps brouillé
avec eux parce que sinon ils avaient
toute leur communauté qui les suivait il
avait des contacts etc bref ça pouvait
le faire du tort d'une manière ou d'une
autre
et en plus il avait donc un double effet
pervers c'est à dire que les gens
avaient envie de suivre ces gars-là est
de faire comme eux pour gagner un peu de
leur faille mais de leurs abonnés et
ouais c'est triste vraiment comme au
collège va suivre des fois des
comportements nul parce que ces
comportements nul là sont vus comme des
trucs cool et on veut faire partie des
mecs cool et là c'est vraiment le même
délire bon du coup lui qui à la vue que
les victimes ont eu le courage de sortir
du silence il se passe quoi là est ce
qu'ils vont payer le prix de leurs actes
ou pas alors légalement il faut qu'il y
ait des poursuites judiciaires qu'il
soit entamée c'est à dire qu'il faut que
des victimes aille en justice les
attaque en justice pour qu'ils aient une
sanction pénale je suis personne pour
remettre à leur place mais je pense que
si j'avais vécu un enfer comme ça
pendant des années j'aurais envie de
tout sauf de raviver ses souvenirs
horribles et de revoir la gueule des
mecs qui m'ont fait tant de mal donc du
coup c'est très compliqué en revanche le
tribunal populaire lui les arts rect
comme on dit suite à la montée en force
des témoignages et à la médiatisation
des noms de certains et ben ils ont tout
simplement été licenciés étaient dégagés
des rédactions ou des agences de pub
dans lesquelles ils travaillaient mais
comment ont-ils réagi face à la montée
des témoignages ils ont sûrement pris
conscience du mal qu'ils ont fait de
leur comportement dangereux et puéril et
ils ont donc fini par faire des excuses
sincères comme tout adulte responsable
pas du tout ben figurez vous que la
plupart d'entre eux quand des
témoignages ont commencé à sortir et que
tout ça a pris un peu de l'ampleur ils
se sont empressés d'aller supprimer l'un
de leurs tweets comme des gros lâche ya
même un gars qui est clasher est harcelé
v'là les gens sur twitter qui a supprimé
78 mille tweets en deux jours imaginez
la taille de la goutte de sueur qui
coulait sur la tempe de ce gars quand il
a vu les gens commencèrent à témoigner
alors attention ils n'ont pas tous réagi
comme ça mais honnêtement quand tu lis
les excuses tu comprends que ils ont pas
du tout pris conscience au moment de
leurs excuses de la gravité de ce qu'ils
ont fait en fait et c'est ça qui est
triste si cette vidéo là peut aider des
gens à comprendre à quel point c'est
grave de faire ça j'ai réussi ma mission
fictif que je me suis donné je suis
content ça aura servi à quelque chose de
faire cette vidéo en fait bref conclut
ont tout ce merdier déjà s'il vous plaît
faites gaffe à part vu cette vidéo je
sais que vous avez la haine contre les
gars qui vont harceler d'autres gens qui
ont fait tant de mal mais ne soyons pas
stupides ne reproduisons pas ce que ces
gars ont fait n'allons pas harceler les
harceleurs c'est débile de faire ça
c'est vraiment un but informatif que
j'ai fait cette vidéo pour que les gens
est ce que c'est que le harcèlement et
qui ne reproduise surtout pas
consciemment ou inconsciemment ces
agissements horrible deuxièmement je
rappelle que le harcèlement c'est un
truc que ya essentiellement dans les
cours de récréation au collège ou lycée
il ya d'ailleurs une journée annuelle
contre le harcèlement pourquoi c'est
essentiellement au collège et au lycée
parce que c'est une phase où on se
construit ou le moyen le plus simple de
se mettre en avant
c'est en rabaissant un autre mais où on
est un âge on se rend pas compte de ce
qu'on lui fait à cette personne du mal
qu'on fait on se rend pas compte qu'on
harcèle si vous êtes jeune et que vous
regardez cette vidéo sachez que ce n'est
pas du tout drôle où coulent de
racketter de frapper quelqu'un de
l'insulté ou de se moquer de lui tous
les jours que ce soit dans la vie ou
virtuellement le cyber harcèlement c'est
au même plan que le harcèlement ça fait
autant de mal c'est la même chose c'est
pas parce qu'un l'écran que c'est
différent c'est exactement pareil faire
ça c'est pas du tout style et c'est pas
du tout cool et ça vous rendra pas du
tout meilleurs aux respectables pas du
tout troisièmement pourquoi parler de la
ligue du lol parce que c'est une bonne
occasion pour remettre les pendules à
l'heure sur ce qu'est le harcèlement et
ses conséquences et surtout j'étais
vraiment scotché en découvrant sa moi
j'ai pas du tout vécu de harcèlement
même étendue ni par ces mecs ni par
d'autres mais j'étais scotché de voir
que l'on peut être un adulte on peut
avoir la vingtaine la trentaine avoir un
taff et faire ça comme une grosse merde
quoi c'est fou peu importe notre âge on
peut pas encaisser d'être traîné comme
ça publiquement dans la boue d'être
isolé d'être moquée de voir son identité
usurpée par un autre qui est mal
intentionnés on peut pas que tu es 13
ans ou 30 ans ces agissements là ils
seront jamais marrant ce sera jamais
drôle ça fera toujours mal
et bravo bravo parce que vous avez
réussi à sortir du silence alors ça doit
être une chose terrifiante est très
difficile et vous les avez kane et c'est
ce qu'ils méritent et pour avoir fait ça
et maintenant c'est la vraie justice
j'espère qu'il va s'en occuper et
j'espère que ça donnera beaucoup moins
envie aux gens d'avoir ces comportements
là je le rappelle si vous regardez cette
vidéo il vous êtes victime de
harcèlement ou de cyber harcèlement ne
vous isolez pas surtout il faut en
parler à vos amis à votre famille à vos
proches quand même un numéro qui a été
mis en place par l'état que vous pouvez
appeler si vous souffrez tous les jours
de harcèlement ils vous aideront et
aussi si vous n'êtes pas forcément
victime de harcèlement mais que vous
souhaitez aider concrètement les gens
qui ont vécu cet enfer il existe une
cagnotte qui a été lancée par la
fondation des femmes et c'est une
cagnotte qui vise à soutenir les frais
de justice des femmes victimes de cyber
harcèlement je le rappelle les femmes
sont les premières à être victime de
harcèlement que ce soit en ligne ou dans
la cour de récréation donc voilà si vous
voulez exprimer votre soutien direct
envers ces personnes n'hésitez pas qui
suis-je pour parler de ça alors je suis
un mec j'en sais rien mais si je peux
utiliser ma notoriété pour tenter
d'aider et d'améliorer la situation
d'autres gens qui vivent un truc injuste
et horrible bah tant mieux je suis ravi
voilà je pense que j'ai tout dit
j'espère m'être bien exprimer et voilà
je vous fais plein de bisous c'était un
peu bas dans ce sujet mais c'était très
important d'en parler la ligue du lol
c'était vraiment la bonne occasion pour
en parler et voilà mercenariat la vidéo
bad est pas au contraire c'est très
positif ce qui se passe l'effet boule de
neige là il est positif grâce à ces gens
qui sont sorties du silence merci avait
encore une foi et courage
et puis à bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo plus positif je vous fais des
bisous à bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]